hi welcome to version control I'm
Caroline one of your instructors for the
course and I'm Sarah your other
instructor in this course will cover the
concept of version control and why you
might want to use it yeah so version
control is sort of like having a giant
undo button for your project you mean
like this one yeah exactly it makes it
easy to save versions of your files at
different points in time you can also
restore previous versions and compare
different versions yeah it also makes it
a lot easier to collaborate with other
people no more sending huge zip files of
your project back and forth now learn to
use version control is a little bit like
learning to type it's hard at first but
once you can do it it makes you a lot
more efficient mm-hmm you might feel
like learning a whole new system to keep
track of versions of your files there's
a lot of work and maybe not worth it or
that if you're hardcore enough you don't
need version control but if you look at
successful software companies like
Google and Facebook you'll find they all
use version control internally what
about you Caroline well when I first
started using version control I
basically only used it when I needed to
but now I like to use it for all of my
projects it's kind of addicting cool
let's find out why